die weihnachtsmärkte in sachsen und auch
in thüringen wurde schon einiges von ihm
abgesagt der grund war dass die kommunen
angst hatten vor der kommenden kroner
schutzverordnung der ministerpräsident
aller sachsen michael kretschmer hat
sich dann heute auch gemälde zu wort
gemeldet und gesagt ja die
weihnachtsmärkte sollten nicht
stattfinden in seinen worten klang das
dann so das sind bürgermeister und
landräte sind die marktbetreiber die
jetzt vor der entscheidung stehen
weihnachtsmärkte abzusagen ihnen sollte
man das klare signal gibt ihr habt recht
die trefft diese schwere entscheidung
ich möchte sagen ich finde nicht dass es
dass die recht haben vor allem weil
viele ist ja absagen aus angst vor der
bewohner schutzverordnung nicht weil
jeder bürgermeister selbst auch davon
überzeugt dass ich würde sagen lasst die
weihnachtsmärkte doch den menschen und
lasst sie dort hingehen und lasst sie
den zauber von weihnachten erleben wie
man es dann umsetzen darüber kann man ja
debattieren
ja wenn ich da starten darf ich sehe es
tatsächlich ganz genau so nena also
wofür haben wir uns den impfen lassen
uns wurde ja immer versprochen wenn wir
geimpft sind dann gibt es lockerungen
und ich finde natürlich sind viele
regulationen sinnvoll definitiv aber
weihnachtsmärkte da können die menschen
ja selber entscheiden gehe ich hin oder
gehe ich nicht hin es ist nicht wie eine
apotheke oder im supermarkt an der heydt
auch hin muss das stimmt natürlich
also ich glaube wir sind alle ziemlich
genervt von corinna mittlerweile haben
gedacht so spätestens wenn dann alle in
empfang gebot bekommen haben dann ist
das endlich vorbei und dann kriegen alle
auch ihre freiheit zurück ich habe das
selber auch noch vor ein paar wochen
geglaubt aber die aktuellen entwicklung
sind natürlich wirklich alles andere als
gut und wenn die intensivstation jetzt
reihenweise überlastet und überfüllt
sind dann müssen wir das thema natürlich
irgendwie neu diskutieren ich glaube
ganz wichtig ist dass man nochmal
werbung macht dafür dass jetzt auch
gebucht hat wird weil viele ältere in
deutschland die jetzt vor sieben acht
monaten eine impfung bekommen haben die
haben mittlerweile nicht mehr den vollen
schutz und gerade die müssen wir
natürlich auch schützen das ist häufig
viel wichtiger als die jüngeren die
natürlich nicht unter den folgen von
corona so leiden wenn sie als crooner
virus bekommen ja aber warum schaffen
sie das denn nicht sie sind doch
mitglied einer regierungspartei
und in deutschland wird viel zu langsam
gewusst hat wenn sie sich mal
großbritannien anschauen das sind
hunderttausende pro tag und das seit
wochen und wir kommen dann nicht mal
ansatzweise hinterher also wenn booster
die lösung ist also booster für ältere
und weihnachtsmärkte stattfinden zu
lassen um eine weitere lockt es zu
verhindern warum machen sie es doch
nicht einfach wer die angebote gibt es
ja also ich glaube wir müssen noch ein
bisschen stärker wieder die
eigenverantwortung in den mittelpunkt
rücken also ich glaube die menschen
müssen einfach jetzt wissen wenn
weihnachten so sein soll wie wir uns das
alle wünschen dann sollten sich
möglichst viele auch buch stand aber
glauben sie mir ich soll ist noch nicht
ja ich glaube dass das bei 4 und
tatsächlich noch nicht so angekommen ist
viele haben gedacht okay spätestens
möchte den zweiten peaks bekommen habe
dann bin ich raus aus der sache dann
haben wir krone hinter uns und wir
wissen jetzt dass das nicht ganz der
fall ist das heißt die politik hat die
menschen immer noch nicht genug
informiert
das würde ich so nicht sagen wir sind ja
alle auch von entwicklungen überrascht
worden also es gibt virologen die selber
sagen wir hätten einige entwicklungen
vor zwei drei vier monate her gesehen
neben alexander rainha ist es so krank
ist ist einfach neue entwicklung
eingetreten konnte man das nicht vorher
sind das jetzt wieder vor demselben
dilemma stehen wie letztes jahr musste
man das voraussehen das ist ja klar es
wurde ja davor gewarnt und zum anderen
finde ich also zugangsbeschränkungen für
weihnachtsmärkte generell falsch und
übertrieben der spielen sich unter
freiem himmel ab großteils unter freiem
himmel haben wir ein sehr geringes
virales geschehen das sagen alle rosol
forscher also ich würd sagen lasst jeden
auf die weihnachtsmessen
weihnachtsmärkte offenes ohr für alle
ohne zugangsbeschränkungen für alle
ausnahmen wenn es innen
veranstaltungsräume gibt dann würde ich
sagen 3g testung für allen ist man
frisch getestet rheinland pfalz hat eine
ähnliche lösung baden württemberg eine
ganz andere aber ich finde ein
weihnachts vergnügen ein bisschen auch
den geist von weihnachten familie in
rechnung stellen sollte für alle
zugänglich so einen test auf für
geimpfte für innenräume müsste man das
überlegen ja müsste man überlegen ich
finde da ist aber auch ein ganz
spannender punkt vor allem die menschen
haben ja auch die ware bestellt die
händler ist wohl noch zu lang der
weihnachtsmarkt findet statt sie haben
damit gerechnet sie haben sich ja auch
dann auf den bürgermeister verlassen auf
die kommunen und ich finde ganz ehrlich
jedes mal zu sagen sorry
haben wir jetzt nicht vorausgesehen bild
alle ware wieder zurückzuschicken das
geld wirst du auch nicht verdient aber
der start der geht für dich rein der
gibt die geld viele menschen sind auch
nicht gern finanziell abhängig vom staat
und das muss ich auch sagen das stört
mich so immens daran dass jetzt auch die
weihnachtsmärkte wieder nicht
stattfinden wir wissen viele für viele
menschen ist es auch denn das
jahreseinkommen die glühweinstände zum
beispiel das brauchen die ja auch die
schausteller absolutes und hat gesagt
die kirmes wie soll man das denn jetzt
wieder einmal wieder ich kann das
verstehen ich habe auch immer in der
ganzen debatte gesagt wir müssen auf die
kollateralschäden achten nicht für
jugendliche für kinder für viele dienen
gewerbe haben und monatelang das gar
nicht richtig aus werbe- und nimmt für
den weihnachtsmarkt
na also ist dass es gab ja sehr sehr
viele folgeschäden auch durch die lok
downs und natürlich durch die korona
krise ist ja völlig klar und ich fand
auch immer richtig dass viele in der
debatte darauf hingewiesen haben dass
man es nicht nur virologisch betrachten
sollte hab auch häufig dann veröff
nungen geworben und wisla richtigerweise
gesagt man muss da auch vor allem
zielgenau agieren also wenn ich weiss
draußen gibt es kaum ansteckungen dann
brauche ich eine masken pflicht für
jogger zu machen so wie wir das ja in
hamburg auch erlebt haben
weihnachtsmärkte würden sie auch
wirklich glaube also man muss glaube ich
ganz ehrlich sagen wir alle können die
entwicklung in den nächsten wochen im
moment nicht vorausahnen wenn das so
weitergeht wie es in den letzten 12
wochen gegangen ist dann sind bald viele
intensivstationen völlig überfüllt stand
haben wir dann bilder haben wir in ich
glaub stand heute ja auch eben mit zwei
regeln aber wenn wir bilder erleben wie
in bergamo es wenn man dieses schlagwort
was wir hier in den debatten auch sehen
dann wird sich auch in deutschland das
wieder alles um kindern wenn viele sagen
so jetzt müssen wir wieder zurück halten
dass sein das ist durch das bittere auch
bei dieser krise
was mach ich gedacht hatte man ist über
den berg und jetzt von dieser jüngsten
entwicklung auch etwas überrascht wird
ich finde aber man muss ja auch ganz
klar sagen weihnachtsmärkte finden
draußen standen also wir sind ja an der
frischen luft regen finden noch mal
diesen corona winter diesen corona blues
nutze machen ist auch da muss man ja
auch mal über depressionen und so
geschichten die hier für dich dafür die
wo die menschen zu hause sitzen und ich
wir reden ja nicht von irgendeinem club
wo wir sagen der soll offen bleiben ja
aber ich finde weihnachtsmarkt an der
frischen luft das also zweig als ich für
völlig unnötig unter frischen luft kann
mir auch keine erkennen warum ich in der
frischen luft zweig diskriminierung
machen soll warum denn es gibt kaum
übertragung und wenn ich sicher zum
impfen zu zwängen ja aber das ist ja
genau das falsche wenn ich das nur so
als als pädagogisches instrument nehmen
nach dem motto ich erhöhe den druck so
dass ich ganz knapp an der pflicht
vorbeikomme aber dennoch nötig ist und
dass du nicht mehr frei entscheiden
kannst dich so eine gewissermaßen die
impfung haben musst als eintrittskarte
für ein einigermaßen normales leben das
entfernt sich von altem konzept was wir
sonst haben von der vom informierten vom
mündigen patienten der in freier
entscheidung die entscheidung trifft das
ist völlig in ordnung dafür zu werben
aber bitte nicht überzeugen bitte nicht
über bitte nicht überreden und wieder
nicht zwingen wobei es gibt ja schon auf
viele dieser wenn zur richtige
massenveranstaltungen sind also alle
kommen dichtgedrängt zusammen dann ist
auch die ansteckung frage hast du auch
im freien aber gab es bisher noch nicht
so super berlin wenn es habe immer noch
ganz am anfang bei den fußballspielen
gab schon für die übertragung also als
alle dicht gedrängt in der fankurve
standen da hat sich als crooner virus
auf verbreitet noch trotzdem ist das
risiko viel geringer und wo bleibt denn
da die eigenverantwortung des bürgers
zum beispiel also zum beispiel als ich
mich verlobt 2020 war ganz klar wir
werden nicht während der kroner zeit
heiraten ganz klar und auch jetzt wieder
nein wir werden diesen sommer nicht
machen wahrscheinlich dann erst 2023 das
war meine eigene verantwortliche
entscheidung als bürgerin dass ich in
dieser zeit keine hochzeit mit 2 300
leuten machen will oder nur im sommer
und wetter ist ja bereits da nicht du
bist für ganz viel freiheit wir sind ja
oft sehr oft einer maya aber was würdest
du denn machen wenn du siehst die
intensivstationen laufen einfach voll
und es hört nicht auf wenn du dir die
zahlen an schaust bei den intensivbetten
die die die kurve so es steigt einfach
also was machen wir einfach sagen ein
eigenverantwortung und abwarten bis die
betten voll sind ich würde ich würde mir
anschauen also der erste punkt ist ja in
der sache muss man sich erst mal den
incidents wert hin dass du hier schon
ganz oft angeprangert dass der
panikmache ist du redest jetzt über die
hospitalisierung rate mit
intensivstation und da frage ich mich
wirklich philipp und das ist meine frage
ich habe die pandemie nicht von anfang
an organisiert aber wie kann es denn
sein dass jetzt nach zwei jahren die
intensiv wieder überlaufen wie lange
dauert es denn intensivbetten
herzustellen wie lange ist das personal
der villa das personal auszubilden auch
das muss ich mich wirklich fragen
mittlerweile also wie sie habe man muss
nun bei dem zweiten jahr wie viele
betten wurden aufgestockt wie viel
personal pool darauf an den betten der
die betten sind das problem sondern und
da da aber das ja der entscheidende
punkt viele sagen sie halten die
situation nicht mehr aus pflegekräfte
ärzte design das haben sie nicht mehr
und die gehen dann und ich glaube an die
müssen wir auch denken an die
pflegekräfte und ärzte sind wir jetzt
einfach sagt sie alle können feiern
totale freiheit und es kommen immer mehr
auf die intensivstation und die ärzte
und pflegekräfte müssen entscheiden wen
nehmen wir auch 1 1 und ist das
natürlich für die anderen xtreme lassen
dass er nächstes jahr also ich verstehe
auch hier philips ein hat aber wie wir
das nächstes jahr im winter sein ich
glaube im moment kann das tatsächlich
keiner sagen also was ja alle virologen
auch sagen ist dass das impfen extrem
hilft weil diejenigen zumindest auch
einen viel stärkeren schutz haben und
man so das virus am ende sogar besiegen
kann wenn wir eine sehr hohe impfquoten
davon sind wir im moment noch weit
entfernt aber wenn wir die nicht haben
dann kann es sein dass auch der nächste
winter und übernächste winter uns vor
große probleme stellt deswegen glaube
ich müssen wir fürs impfen werben und
auch wirklich sagen das ist nicht nur
eine sache die man aus sich selbst
heraus betrachten sollte so nach dem
motto ich lasse mich schützen oder nicht
sondern das ist auch ganz wichtig für
die gesamte gesellschaft ich habe das
gefühl wir lernen teilweise nicht
vernünftig daraus finde ich das ist auch
so ein bisschen das problem dass es
nicht umgesetzt wird ist man müde wird